how does our level of self-confidence
affect our performance the answer to
this question is simple a great deal
feeling confident about our ability to
complete a task makes us feel good when
we're doing it and helps us do it better
the origins of this Insight can be
traced back to the Canadian American
psychologist Albert bandura drawing on
his research over the previous decade
bandora argued that it's not just our
abilities that are important in human
performance and well-being it's how we
feel about our abilities self-efficacy
was the term he coined to describe such
feelings believing you can is the first
step to making sure you actually can
simply by becoming your own hype team
you can dramatically impact your own
productivity I've come up with a few
specific ways you can do so too my
favorite method involves what I call
flipping the confidence switch
challenging yourself to behave as if
you're confident in your task even if
you're not next time you're feeling like
a task or project is particularly
difficult ask yourself what would it
look like if I were really confident at
this just by asking yourself the
question you'll visualize yourself
confidently approaching the task at hand
the switch has been flipped